Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the of course, as ever, is Dominic Sandbrook. And Dominic, you remember in the episode we did on Valentine's Day. Remember it well, Tom. You, of course, bring this amazing expertise on the post office and you talked about how the invention of basically of the kind of, you know, the penny post revolutionized the sending of Valentine cards because everyone could send them anonymously and all that. Exactly. That and the pillar box, two great
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishight.com 并加入。当然，一如既往，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。多米尼克，你还记得我们在情人节那天做的节目吗。当然记得，汤姆。你当然带来了关于邮政局的惊人专业知识，你谈到了基本上类似那种，你知道的，一便士邮政的发明是如何彻底改变了情人节贺卡的寄送方式的，因为每个人都可以匿名寄送贺卡，诸如此类。没错。那个和邮筒，这两个被严重低估的伟大
inventions that are underestimated. Well, it set me thinking, which of course you do all the time, but this really set me thinking that in, in so in central london just i should think five minutes walk north of maybe 10 minutes walk north of saint paul's cathedral um there's a statue of roland hill postal reformer the father of the penny post absolutely and it marks a spot where there was that it was the the main post office in victorian time so the mid-19th century and next door to it there's this very sweet very kind of discreet park called Postman's Park. And obviously, and I looked up to check this, it's because all the postmen went there to have a rest after they'd done their rounds. I'm keen to hear where this is going, Tom.
发明。好吧，这让我陷入了沉思，虽然你一直在思考，但这确实让我想到，在伦敦市中心，我想从圣保罗大教堂往北步行大约五分钟，或者说步行大约十分钟的地方，嗯，有一座罗兰·希尔的雕像，他是邮政改革者，一便士邮政之父。绝对的。它标志着维多利亚时代（即19世纪中叶）主要邮局所在的地方。而它的隔壁，有一个非常可爱、非常低调的公园，叫做“邮递员公园”。显然，我查证过了，这是因为所有的邮递员在送信结束后都会去那里休息。我很想知道这番话最终会引向何方，汤姆。
Okay, I'll tell you where it's going. postman's park is the fact that in 1900 the um the artist george frederick watts you know he did kind of great victorian slight you know uh canvases he did burning burning summer i think was it yeah he did but he was very kind of slightly sort of post pre-raphaelite kind of very lush kind of stuff i kind of huge metal statues i think he's got a bronze in hyde park anyway he he set up this wonderful thing that was a memorial to heroic self-sacrifice. And they are kind of little, well, they're little memorials that are on the side of the wall commemorating people who sacrificed themselves saving fellow citizens in Victorian London. And the very first one to appear,
好吧，我来告诉你它会引向何方。邮递员公园的奇妙之处在于，在1900年，嗯，艺术家乔治·弗雷德里克·沃茨（你知道的，他画过那种伟大的维多利亚时期稍微有点，你知道的，画布作品，他画过《燃烧的盛夏》，我想是吧？是的，他画过，但他带有那种稍微有点前拉斐尔派风格的，非常浓郁的东西，还有巨大的金属雕像，我想他在海德公园有一个青铜雕像）总之，他设立了这个奇妙的东西，用来纪念英勇的自我牺牲精神。它们是立在墙边的小型纪念碑，用来纪念在维多利亚时代的伦敦为了拯救同胞而牺牲自己的人。而出现的第一个纪念碑，
the first one to be mentioned, is Sarah Smith, pantomime artiste at the Prince's Theatre, died of terrible injuries received when attempting, in her inflammable dress, to extinguish the flames which had enveloped her companion, January the 24th, 1863. And the reason that this particularly sticks in my memory is that I saw this and was very, very struck by it. And I mentioned it to my younger daughter, Eliza, who you know well. And she said, oh, well, in that case, you must read this amazing book I've got. She has this incredible library of books about fashion. And this book, she said, absolutely her favourite book.
第一个被提及的是萨拉·史密斯，王子剧院的哑剧演员，在试图用她那易燃的衣服熄灭吞噬她同伴的火焰时，遭受了可怕的伤害而去世，时间是1863年1月24日。这件事之所以特别深刻地印在我的记忆中，是因为我看到了它，并为此感到非常非常震撼。我把这件事讲给了我的小女儿伊莉莎听，你对她很熟悉。她说：“哦，好吧，既然这样，你必须读读我这本神奇的书。”她有一个关于时尚的不可思议的书籍藏书。她说这本书绝对是她最喜欢的书。
And it was called Fashion Victims, The Dangers of Dress, Past and Present by Alison Matthews David. And she pressed it on me. And I have to say that her commendation was entirely merited because it is a brilliant book. Well, Tom, I've got a great surprise for you. Oh, yeah? Yeah, you'll be absolutely astounded to find that we have with us right now alison matthews david no joining us from toronto in canada i think our first canadian guest on the well our first canadian based guest we've had canadians before andrew preston of course
这本书名叫《时尚受害者：过去与现在的着装危险》，作者是艾莉森·马修斯·大卫。她把这本书强推给了我。我必须说，她的推荐完全实至名归，因为这是一本极其精彩的书。汤姆，我给你准备了一个巨大的惊喜。哦，是吗？是的，你会惊讶地发现，此时此刻陪着我们的正是来自加拿大多伦多的艾莉森·马修斯·大卫。我想这是我们在节目中迎来的第一位加拿大嘉宾，嗯，第一位常驻加拿大的嘉宾。我们以前也接待过加拿大人，当然有安德鲁·普雷斯顿，
but um alison uh tom has been banging on about your book for, I would say, about 18 months. He's very excited about it, as am I, because it is a brilliant book. It's about killer fashion, basically, isn't it? What brought you to this sort of strange subject? Well, I suppose I've been a fashion or dress and textiles historian for about 20 years. And actually, I have been to Postman's Park and I've seen that plaque. It's quite, it's very moving. But the story does start in the UK because I started my academic career at the Winchester School of Art.
但是，艾莉森，汤姆一直在喋喋不休地谈论你的书，我想大概有18个月了吧。他对这本书非常兴奋，我也是，因为它确实是一本杰出的书。它基本上是关于杀手级时尚的，对吧？是什么促使你涉足这个如此奇特的主题的呢？嗯，我想我担任时尚、服装和纺织品历史学家已经大约20年了。实际上，我去过邮递员公园，也见过那块牌匾。它非常、非常感人。但这个故事确实是从英国开始的，因为我的学术生涯是从温彻斯特艺术学院开始的。
And we took field trips up to Manchester. And that's where I really, the scale of how much harm the textile and fashion industry had done to the people who worked in it and wore it really hit me. Because that's where I first saw sort of the cotton machinery that, you know, children would get trapped in, would deafen the workers, you know, tuberculosis transmitted through shuttles. So really that kind of the harm caused by the mills really inspired me to look more deeply into all of these harmful things that harmed health through fashion. Yeah. And so you wrote this incredible book, Fashion Victims, which is absolutely lavishly illustrated as well as being full of, I mean, literally killer facts. So we should just say you're now a professor in the School of Fashion at Ryerson University in Toronto. You're working on a second book which sounds equally brilliant has an equally brilliant title the fabric of crime uh and you've got a you've got a show coming out exhibit a investigating crime and footwear which is opening at the battersea museum in toronto so
我们曾去曼彻斯特进行实地考察。正是在那里，纺织和时尚产业对在其间工作以及穿着它的人们造成了多大伤害，这种伤害的规模才真正震撼了我。因为正是在那里，我第一次见到了那种棉纺机械，你知道的，儿童会被卷入其中，会震聋工人的耳朵，你知道的，通过梭子传播结核病。所以，真正是工厂造成的这种伤害，启发我去更深入地研究所有这些通过时尚危害健康的有害事物。是的。于是你写了这本不可思议的书《时尚受害者》，它不仅内容充满了——简直是字面意义上的——夺命事实，而且插图极其华丽。我们应该顺便说一下，你现在是多伦多瑞尔森大学时尚学院的教授。你正在创作第二本听起来同样精彩、书名也同样棒的书——《犯罪的面料》；而且你有一个即将推出的展览“证据A：调查犯罪与鞋类”，将在多伦多的巴特西博物馆开幕，所以
um very disappointing for people in britain that we won't be able to get to see it. But perhaps it will travel. Well, let's hope, let's hope. But the fab, so you're obviously brilliant at your titles, but let's for the moment stick to fashion victims. And if we could just continue to look at the idea of tutus as killers. I mean, Alison, we should say that we've just done
对于英国人来说，去不了现场看展览会非常失望。但也许它会巡展呢。嗯，但愿如此，但愿如此。不过，这本书——所以你显然在起书名方面非常有才华，但我们目前还是专注于《时尚受害者》。如果我们能继续探讨芭蕾舞裙（tutu）作为杀手的这个概念。艾莉森，我们应该说，我们刚刚做过
an episode about the 10 worst parties in which actually the tutu does feature. We featured one of them, a very formal dinner in a hunting lodge in the Black Forest attended by the Kaiser in, I think, 1910, when the head of the German staff wandered out, dressed up in a tutu, came back in, did some pirouettes and then had a heart attack. So that's the sense I suppose. I don't think it's fair to say that the tutu killed him though, Tom. I mean, in a manner of speaking, but that's not what we're talking about here, is it? We're talking about the fact that, I mean, you have this amazing statistic, 10,000 deaths worldwide from theatre fires between 1797 and 1897, of which most were dancers. So what's going on there? Oh, it's a complex story, but certainly an important one, I think. And it's tied to so
一期关于十大糟糕派对的节目，其中其实就出现了芭蕾舞裙。我们重点讲了其中一个派对，那是1910年左右由德皇出席的黑森林一个狩猎小屋里的正式晚宴，当时德国总参谋部负责人穿着芭蕾舞裙晃悠着走出去，又走回来，转了几个圈，然后心脏病发作了。所以我想就是这种感觉。不过，汤姆，把这归咎于芭蕾舞裙杀了他，我觉得不太公平。我是说，某种意义上可以说是，但我们今天讨论的不是这个，对吧？我们讨论的是这样一个事实：你有这样一个惊人的统计数据，在1797年到1897年间，全球有10,000人死于剧院火灾，其中大多数是舞者。那么这到底是怎么回事呢？哦，这是一个复杂的故事，但绝对是一个重要的故事。它与这么多
many things, literally, including the fact, again, to go back to the kind of industrial production, one of the things was that tulle, you know, the kind of that net fiber that we associate with the tutu could first be mass produced in 1808. John Heathcote invented a machine to weave. It was one of the most complex textile machines that have ever been invented, but it was a mechanical way of weaving tool. And so this luxury fabric that was then, you know, for the rest of the 19th century became an incredibly important both a fashion fabric for net dresses, it was called bobinette, but also for dancers, because this light fabric in combination with the lighting,
事情息息相关，字面意义上的息息相关，包括这样一个事实：再次回到工业化生产上来，其中一件事就是网眼纱（tulle），你知道的，那种我们与芭蕾舞裙联系在一起的网状纤维，是在1808年首次实现大规模生产的。约翰·希思科特发明了一种织网机器。这是有史以来最复杂的纺织机械之一，但它是一种机械化织网的方法。因此，这种奢侈面料在整个19世纪剩下的时间里，不仅成为了一种极其重要的网眼连衣裙时尚面料（被称为bobinette），而且也成为了舞者的专属面料，因为这种轻盈的面料与灯光相结合，
created this diaphanous, beautiful, you know, kind of figure of the romantic ballerina, whose legs were who could, you know, dance en pointe, which was the, you know, kind of figure of the romantic ballerina, whose legs were, who could, you know, dance en pointe, which was, you know, the first time that this was happening in her light tool tutu, and, you know, layers of different kind of petticoats. And she created this sort of enchanting figure wafting around the stage. But of course, these same materials in the same form of lighting. Also, unfortunately, you know, these tutus were starched, you know, they were open weave. You can imagine an accommodation with gaslighting created an incredible fire hazard on stage. And people knew it. You see, that to me is one of the amazing things about your book,
创造出了空灵美丽、你知道的，那种浪漫芭蕾舞演员的形象，她的双腿，可以，你知道的，跳着足尖舞，这，你知道的，浪漫芭蕾舞演员的形象，她的双腿，可以，你知道的，跳着足尖舞，你知道的，这是历史上第一次发生这种情况，她穿着轻盈的网眼纱芭蕾舞裙，以及，你知道的，多层不同的衬裙。她创造了这种令人陶醉的、在舞台上飘然移动的形象。但是，当然，这些相同的材料在同样形式的照明下。不幸的是，你知道的，这些芭蕾舞裙上了浆，你知道的，它们是稀疏的织物。你可以想象，在煤气灯的配合下，在舞台上造成了难以置信的火灾隐患。而且人们是知道这一点的。你看，这对我来说是你这本书最神奇的地方之一，
is that it's not just about, you know, us retrospectively saying, oh, I mean, there are some cases of that, saying, oh, actually, these things killed you. But at the time, so The Lancet, there's an article in 1868, The Holocaust of Ballet Girls. Ballet Girls themselves knew that there was a very, I mean, it's not a very strong possibility, but there is a possibility. But they do it anyway. I mean, I suppose it's that just because they feel they have no choice. The theatres are refusing to flameproof themselves or whatever. I mean, what's the story? Yeah, it's a complex story. And it does relate strongly to occupational dress in a way that we don't think of dance costumes or theatre costumes as occupational dress. But in order to create your character or to be a dancer, you need to wear a costume that has a certain allure and whether or not that allure is physically dangerous.
就是它不仅关乎，你知道的，我们事后诸葛亮地说，哦——当然也有一些这样的案例——说，哦，实际上，这些东西会害死你。但在当时，比如《柳叶刀》杂志在1868年发表过一篇文章：《芭蕾舞女郎的大屠杀》。芭蕾舞女郎自己也知道，存在着非常大的——我的意思是，这并不是一种极小的可能性，而是确实存在这种可能性。但她们还是这么做了。我想，这只是因为她们觉得自己别无选择。剧院拒绝进行防火处理等等。我是说，这背后的故事是什么？是的，这是一个复杂的故事。它在某种程度上与职业装密切相关，尽管我们通常不会把舞蹈服装或戏剧服装视为职业装。但为了塑造你的角色或成为一名舞者，你需要穿着一套具有某种诱惑力的服装，而不管这种诱惑力是否具有身体上的危险性。
And certainly theatres were not wonderful or uniform in having, you know, sort of any kind of flame-proofing, fire-proofing, even water buckets to put out flames, you know. So it was inherently, and people were, you know, the audience members were also throwing cigars on the floor and things like that. So, you know, there was just not the same concern with safety at the time and safety for the workers, because these most of the, you know, the ballerinas came from working class backgrounds. And of course, you probably know, in Paris, they were even called rats, the little rats. So, you know, they really often came, they were workers with their bodies, right. And so they came from the working class for the most part. And, you know, a lot of the descriptions of them are in kind of, you know, dingy tool, but still, that was what they were expected to wear. And I think that's a,
当然，剧院在配备任何形式的防火处理、阻燃措施、甚至用于扑灭火焰的水桶方面，并不是都做得很好或很规范，你知道的。所以它本质上就是危险的，而且人们，你知道的，观众也会把雪茄扔在地板上之类的事情。所以，你知道的，当时对安全并没有同样的关注，也没有对工人的安全给予同样的重视，因为大多数，你知道的，芭蕾舞女郎都来自工人阶级背景。当然，你可能知道，在巴黎，她们甚至被称为“老鼠”，小老鼠。所以，你知道的，她们确实经常出身于此，她们是用身体工作的劳动者，对吧。所以她们绝大多数都来自工人阶级。而且，你知道的，很多对她们的描述都穿着某种，你知道的，破旧的网眼纱，但即便如此，那也是她们被期望穿的衣服。我认为这是一个，
and they kind of often took on the risks of that knowingly, because that was how they earned their daily bread, I suppose. And they were, yeah, it's amazing throughout this study how much was actually known about the hazards that we, you know, that people were exposed to. And they did try to fireproof fabrics. There's a huge history in there of sort of how fabrics were, how people attempted to fireproof fabrics. There's a huge history in there of sort of how fire, how fabrics were, how people attempted to fireproof them. But gender is also a very important consideration, because men's clothing was inherently, if you're wearing a woolen suit, it's inherently flame
而且她们往往明知故犯地承担这些风险，因为我想这就是她们赚取每日面包的方式。而且她们，是的，在这项研究中令人惊叹的是，当时人们对我们所知道的那些危害的了解到底有多深。而且他们确实试图对织物进行防火处理。其中有一段厚重的历史，讲述了织物是如何被处理的，人们是如何试图对织物进行防火处理的。这里面有一段厚重的历史，关于火灾是如何发生的，织物是如何被处理的，人们是如何试图对它们进行防火处理的。但性别也是一个非常重要的考量因素，因为男性的服装本质上——如果你穿的是一套羊毛西装，它本质上就是阻燃的，
proofed, and it kind of fits your body. Whereas women's dress in the Victorian era, as you can all vision, envision and kind of imagine, especially dress that was worn for, again, dance or evening dress was often very gauzy, very layered, loose from the body, you know, crinolines, we can get into that. But, you know, it wasn't fitted to the body, it was made of these light fabrics that were often incredibly flammable. So, yeah. Well, so Alison, you mentioned crinolines. So again, the Lancet seems to be quite hot on this. So again, I mean, in 1860, it described the wearing of women who were wearing crinolines. It described, again, that this is causing a holocaust. So this is long, obviously, before the Shoah. This is referring to, you know, burnt offerings. And what is it about crinolines that are so dangerous? Yes. I mean, I was actually shocked to find those articles called the Holocaust of Ballet Girls or the crinoline, because I didn't know that it came from the, to be meant to be burnt whole. And so
而且它很贴合你的身体。而维多利亚时代的女性服装，正如大家所能想象和幻视的那样，尤其是再次用于舞蹈或晚宴的服装，通常非常轻薄、极具层次感、身体周围很宽松，你知道的，裙撑（crinoline），我们一会儿可以聊到这个。但是，你知道的，它并不贴合身体，它是由这些轻质面料制成的，而这些面料通常极易燃。所以，是的。那么，艾莉森，你提到了裙撑。同样，医学杂志《柳叶刀》似乎对这个话题非常热衷。所以，再次，在1860年，它描述了穿着裙撑的女性的行为。它再次描述说，这正在导致一场大屠杀。所以这显然是在“大屠杀”（Shoah）很久之前。这里指的是，你知道的，作为火祭的祭品。那么裙撑到底有什么危险之处，以至于如此危险？是的。事实上，当我看到那些题为《芭蕾舞女郎的大屠杀》或《裙撑》的文章时，我也感到震惊，因为我不知道它源自那个词，意为被整体烧毁。因此，
that, but it was a word that came up in the 19th century press a lot in relation to these fire deaths. But the crinoline was also a culprit. The crinoline also called a skeleton petticoat, ironically, perhaps, or the hoop skirt as we know it more in North America. But the crinoline was a device that was a skirt supporter. And many people may be familiar with it. But what was new about it, I suppose, was that it was made from steel hoops. So it used steel technology in the 1850s and replaced layers of really heavy, you know, horse hair, horse hair, petticoats that dragged around. And so on the one hand, the crinoline was fantastic. A lot of women loved, you know, you had to have a bell shaped skirt. You had to, you know, show off all the textiles you had and all your lace and all your trimmings. And also because men couldn't reach over and molest them, right? You just kind of physically
这一点——但这个词在19世纪的报刊中经常与这些火灾死亡事件联系在一起。不过，裙撑本身也是罪魁祸首。裙撑也被称为“骨架衬裙”（或许讽刺的是），或者就像我们在北美更常称呼的那样——裙 hoop skirt。但裙撑是一种裙撑支撑装置。许多人可能对此很熟悉。不过，它新颖的地方，我想在于它是用钢制圆圈制成的。所以在19世纪50年代，它采用了钢铁技术，取代了那些拖拖拉拉的、真正沉重的马毛、马毛衬裙。因此，一方面，裙撑真是太棒了。许多女性喜欢，你知道的，你必须拥有一条钟形裙。你必须，你知道的，炫耀你拥有的所有纺织品、所有的蕾丝和所有的饰边。而且，这也是因为男人无法伸手过来骚扰她们，对吧？你只需在物理上
repel them. Exactly. I mean, it was amazing to me with the pandemic, how many people tested the crinoline as a kind of social distancing measure, actually. A lot of people went out in public with them and kind of, you know, just to keep people away. And so they would have done that in a world where women were, you know, touched and molested and things like that. It was a natural space. You know, women claimed their space, which made it very unpopular for men and in the caricatures. But I mean, I'm always torn. And women did find it because it was light steel, you know, attached by tapes. It was actually apparently much more comfortable to walk in. It wasn't as heavy.
击退他们。没错。对我来说，在疫情期间，有那么多人把裙撑作为一种社交距离测量工具来进行测试，这真是太神奇了。许多人穿着它们走上公共场所，你知道的，只是为了让人们保持距离。因此，在那个女性经常被触摸和骚扰的世界里，她们本可以这样做。这是一个自然的物理空间。你知道的，女性宣示了自己的空间，这使得它在男性的讽刺漫画中变得非常不受欢迎。不过，话说回来，我总是感到纠结。女性确实发现它——因为它是轻质钢，由带子连接——实际上走起路来明显更舒适，没有那么沉重。
So it did have a lot of pluses. But one of the biggest dangers, and I think one that gets, as I think, increasingly on this got picked up on by the press and the caricaturists, was that it was, and the Lancet, and the medical experts, was that it was a fire hazard. And indeed, it actually was. Because, you know, if you think about it, people compared it to a chimney flue, you know, so it would just, the air would whoosh under it, you know if you think about it people compared it to a a chimney flew um you know so it would just the air would whoosh under it you know if even a spark caught it the air would um you know whoosh under it and and you know kind of blaze up and so there were actually and it was worn across the social spectrum like in the past this is the thing that's different from the tutus right because the people wearing the tutus are working class girls who feel they
所以它确实有很多优点。但其中最大的危险之一——而且我认为这也是越来越被媒体、讽刺漫画家、《柳叶刀》以及医学专家们所关注的一点——就是它是一个火灾隐患。事实上，它确实是。因为，如果你仔细想想，人们把它比作烟囱烟道，你知道的，所以空气就会在它下面呼呼作响，如果你仔细想想，人们把它比作烟囱烟道，嗯，你知道的，空气就会在它下面呼呼作响，你知道的，即使有一颗火星溅到它上面，空气也会，嗯，你知道的，在它下面呼呼作响，然后（你知道的）燃起大火，因此实际上——而且它跨越了社会各阶层被穿着，就像过去一样，这就是它与芭蕾舞裙的不同之处，对吧？因为穿芭蕾舞裙的是那些觉得别无选择、只能上台表演的工人阶级女孩，而且成为一名芭蕾舞演员，正如你将要指出的，但裙撑的一些受害者，比如奥地利女大公、女大公玛蒂尔达、奥斯卡·王尔德的姐姐们，她们在舞会上去世，其中一个走过壁炉，我想是这样的，然后着火了，另一个试图去扑灭她身上的火。我的意思是，这些——这就是区别，这些是高级阶层。我的意思是，Certainly以奥地利女大公为例，那是国内最高阶层了。没有比这更高的了。
have no choice but to go on the stage and a ballet being a ballet dancer as you'll root up but some of the victims with the crinolines the archduchess of austria archduchess matilda's it oscar wilde's sisters who die at a ball one of them goes past the fireplace i think it is and catches fire and then the other one tries to to put her out i mean these are so that's the difference these are high these are upper class. I mean, certainly in the case of the Archduchess of Austria, the very highest class in the land. You don't get higher than that.
但是，然而，它仍在继续。这才是最了不起的事情。没错，因为，你知道的，我们认为作为一个上流社会或中上层阶级的女性，你也许有选择穿得稍微更保守一点的权利，除了社会对顺从时尚的压力如此之大，以至于我认为她们其实也没有什么特别的选择，对吧？嗯，所以——我的意思是，同样有趣的是，玛蒂尔达女大公也是，你知道的，又是一位年轻年轻的女性，据说她当时把一支香烟藏在身后。她在抽烟。
But still, but still, it goes on. That's the extraordinary thing. Exactly, because, you know, we think that as an upper class or middle or upper class woman, you might have a choice to wear something a little bit more, except that the social pressure to conform to fashion was such that i would argue that they didn't particularly have a choice either right um and so i mean again it's interesting too that the archduchess matilda was you know again the young young woman apparently she was hiding a cigarette from her behind her back. She was smoking.
而报纸的报道却说：“哦，她踩到了一根火柴。”他们不想承认她一直在抽烟。所以，你知道的，这种放荡的行为，我想。但是每个人——当我阅读报道时——从是的，女大公到女厨师都在穿它。想象一下穿着这些衣服，或者一个刚清理完壁炉的的女佣，她的裙撑和裙子着了火。因此，裙撑并不是天生就很昂贵的。不，不。大多数女性大约拥有两件，甚至在较低阶层中也是如此。而且这并不是说，
And the press records say, oh, she stepped on a match. They didn't want to say that she had been smoking. So, you know, this fast behaviour, I suppose. But everyone, when I read reports, everyone from, yes, the Archduchess to cooks were wearing it. You know, imagine wearing these, or a maid who had been cleaning the fire grate had her crinoline, her skirts catch on fire. So crinolines, therefore, weren't intrinsically expensive. No, no. Most women owned about two of them, even in the lower classes. And it wasn't really,
唯一不穿它们的女性是那些无可救药的人，比如前拉斐尔派成员、波希米亚人或艺术家。所以，你知道的，实际上你就是被期望穿它们的。艾莉森，这有点像芭蕾舞裙，因为你拥有那种使芭蕾舞裙成为可能的新型面料。裙撑不也是如此吗？是一种新型的轻质金属使其成为可能。而且你又有——我相信这是用于旋转的贝塞麦炼钢法（Bessmer steel process）。是的，用来旋转。这完全是新技术注入时尚。然后，你知道的，究竟是谁在从中获利呢？
the only women who didn't wear them were, you know, hopeless, like the pre-athletes, the, you know, the bohemians or the artists. And so, you know, so really you were expected to wear them. And Alison, it's, it's a bit like the tutus in that you have this new kind of style of fabric that makes the tutu possible. Isn't also the same with the crinoline, that it's a kind of new light kind of metal that makes it possible. And you have the, again. I believe it's the Bessemer steel process that's used for it to spin. Yeah, to spin. It's exactly, it's new technology feeding into fashion. And then, you know, who's making the profit from it again?
然后是谁在讽刺它？我认为这是一个非常有趣的现象，你知道，就像，“哦，这些愚蠢的女人，她们怎么敢穿这些东西？”这就好比，那么，究竟是谁在从中获利？又是谁在发明这些东西？佩雷公司（Perchet），对吧？我的意思是，佩雷公司，他们拥有整整一家工厂，现在因汽车而闻名，他们开了一家全新的工厂，
And then who's satirizing it? I think it's a very interesting, you know, it's like, oh, these silly women, how dare they wear these things? And it's like, well, who is profiting from this? And who's inventing these things? Perchet, right? I mean, Perchet, they have an entire factory. Perchet factory known for their cars now opened an entire new factory
专门用来制作钢笼裙撑圈。关于裙子的最后一个话题，在我们转向用衣物杀死自己的另一种方式之前——紧身窄裙（hobble skirt）。是的。汤姆喜欢这个故事。我喜欢一条好的紧身窄裙。
just to make steel cage crinoline hoops. And just one last on the subject of skirts before we move on to another way of killing yourself with items of clothing, the hobble skirt. Yes. Tom loves this story. I love a good hobble skirt.
所以给我们讲讲紧身窄裙——首先，什么是紧身窄裙？我的意思是，这有点顾名思义，对吧？但是，它们是如何诞生的呢？时尚和某些物品的起源很复杂，但我喜欢其中的一种说法：在20世纪初——我的意思是，我们把裙子与女性开始穿裤子、着装改革运动、女性选举权运动等联系在一起。因此，这种女性在着装上的解放变得更具功能性，除了它绝不是一条通往充满活力、自由自在的“飞来波女郎”（flapper）的线性进展。所以在1908年到
So tell us how hobble skirts, well, first of all, what is a hobble skirt? I mean, it's kind of self-descriptive, isn't it? But, and how do they come into being? Fashion, the origins of certain items are complex, but I like one of the versions of this is that in the early 20th century, I mean, we associate, again, with skirts, we associate, you know, women starting to wear trousers and, you know, the dress reform movement and, you know, women's suffrage movements and things like that. And so this sort of liberation and dress for women does become more functional, except that it's never a linear progression to, you know, the mobile flapper. So around 1908 to
1910年左右，一种非常紧身、长度及踝的新型裙子开始流行起来，被称为“紧身窄裙”。如果你想想象紧身窄裙长什么样，你只需要想象一下可口可乐的瓶子，它也被称为紧身窄裙瓶，那种传统的款式，你可以看出它是如何在脚踝处收紧的。所以这些裙子实际上与裙撑截然相反。它们的直径极其狭窄。而且你还要加上“hobble”（羁绊、蹒跚），我的意思是，它束缚了女性的步伐，你必须，你知道的——有些明信片嘲笑它们，说：“我无法踢腿，因为另一件事，
1910, a new kind of very tightly fitting ankle length skirt comes into fashion called the hobble skirt. And if you want to picture what the hobble skirt looks like, you have merely to imagine the Coke bottle, which is also called the hobble skirt bottle, the traditional kind of, and you can see how that's cinched in at the ankles. And so they were skirts that were the opposite of the crinoline, really. They were incredibly narrow in diameter. And you add to hobble, I mean, it hobbled women, you had to, you know, there are postcards mocking them saying, I can't kick because the other thing,
当然，你会用它来羁绊马或骡子。”还有被奴役的人民。所以，你知道的，它带有负面含义，但它成了一种巨大的时尚。我发现了一张非常棒的照片，照片上是莱特兄弟的公关人员伊迪丝·伯格夫人（Mrs. Edith Berg）穿着她的裙子。她于1908年或09年成为了飞机上的第一位女性乘客。她必须——当然飞机是敞开的。所以当她在空中作为乘客时，她不得不必须用绳子把她的裙子绑起来，以防止裙子向上翻飞，为了保持端庄，可能也是出于实际原因。其中一个传说说：“哦，我看到那个女人下飞机时一瘸一拐的，我觉得那很有吸引力。”著名的法国时装设计师保罗·波烈（Paul Poiret）
of course, you'd hobble would be horses or mules. And so, and enslaved peoples. So, you know, it had negative connotations, but it became a huge fashion. And one of the, I have found a great picture of Mrs. Edith Berg, who was the publicist for the Wright brothers with her skirts. She was the first female passenger on an airplane in 19, I think it was 1908 or nine. And she had to, of course, the plane was open. So she had to tie her skirt with ropes to prevent it from flapping up when she was on in the air as a passenger, you know, for modesty and probably practical reasons as well. And one legend sort of says, well, you know, I saw the woman get off the plane and she hobbled and I thought that was very attractive. One of the famous French fashion designers, Paul Poiret,
曾说：“我把胸部从紧身胸衣中解放出来——这是另一个完全不同的故事——但我却给双腿戴上了脚镣。”所以他声称自己发明了这种紧身窄裙。我对他的话持保留态度。但结果是，你知道的，到处都是女性蹦蹦跳跳去赶火车的讽刺漫画，以及女性在下有轨电车时扭伤脚踝等实际事件。或者，你知道的，试图在有轨电车里保持移动之类的，或者，你知道的，在这些紧身窄裙中试图在城市中四处走动是一个真正的挑战。所以紧身窄裙不会致死，但它们会弄断你的脚踝？基本上就是这个故事吗？嗯，确实有一个女人掉进了一个船闸里，然后不会游泳。于是她淹死了。另一个女人无法逃离一匹野马，讽刺的是，是在赛马场上。而且，你知道的，她死于马从她身上踩过去。所以，你知道的，不，并没有那么多，你知道的，实际有记录的死亡人数，但我认为这是一个很有趣的例子，说明了“太阳底下无新事”（plus ça change）。你知道的，危险可能来自于过紧或过松的衣物，但作为穿着者的女性，往往要承受更多的危险。
says, you know, I freed the bust from the corset, which is a whole other story, but I shackled the legs. So he claims that he invented this hobble skirt. I take it with a grain of salt. But the result was that, you know, there are all sorts of, again, caricatures of women hopping to catch the train and actual incidents of women, you know, breaking ankles, getting off the streetcar and things like that. Or, you know, trying to be mobile in the streetcar and things like that, or, you know, trying to be mobile in the city in these hobble skirts was a real challenge. So the hobble skirts don't kill you, but they'll break your ankle. Is that basically the story? Well, one woman did fall into a lock and then couldn't swim. So she drowned. Another woman couldn't escape a wild horse, ironically, from a race course. And, you know, she died with the
所以，在这个话题上，我确实认为时尚的一个重要方面恰恰在于它是令人不舒服、危险和尴尬的，我想真正作为这种现象典型插图的经典鞋履单品就是鞋子。嗯，这是唯一的鞋履单品，汤姆。是的，你说得对，当然是的，对不起，是的，是的，是的，是的，这是唯一的鞋履单品，汤姆。是的，你说得对，
horse running her over. So, you know, no, there weren't as many, you know, she died with the horse running her over. So, you know, no, there weren't as many, you know, actual documented deaths, but I think it's a kind of interesting example of, you know, plus ça change. You know, the hazard can be from either something too tight or too loose, but women are often, as wearers, are often subject to more dangers so so on that topic i do think that um it can be an important aspect of fashion precisely that it is uncomfortable and dangerous and awkward and i guess the the really the the classic item of footwear that is always cited as the illustration of that is shoes well it's the only item of footwear there is tom yeah you're right of course yeah sorry yes yes yes yes it's the only item of footwear there is tom yeah you're right
当然，抱歉，是的，是的，是的，是的，还有靴子——嗯，不，靴子也是，依我看靴子其实是鞋子里的一个子集。是的，你说的对，当然，抱歉，我指的是服装——鞋子嘛，我们有脚，所以高跟鞋所有这些东西，而且不仅限于女性，对吧？让我来说这句话，汤姆，我一直期待着说这句话：上周，有些听众可能知道，我们在伦敦进行了一次徒步旅行，一次历史徒步，而你很清楚我那天晚上得去参加一个活动，穿得非常正式，事实上我两个脚踝上现在还留有很深的伤疤，因为正如汤姆所知，我穿着一双新靴子——我讨厌他为此笑得这么幸灾乐祸。我当时穿着一双新靴子，而那该死的散步却永远也走不到头。
of course yeah sorry yes yes yes yes there's the boots well no boots as well i see boots as a subset of shoes frankly yeah you're right of course sorry i meant clothing um the the shoes are well we're feet so so high heels all that kind of stuff and it's not just women is it let me just say this tom i've been looking forward to saying this the other week listen some listeners may know that we did a walk around london a historical walk and you knew perfectly well that i had to go to a function that evening and was very smartly dressed and i actually still have deep scars on both ankles because i was wearing as tom knows i hate the fact that he's laughing so gleefully at this. I was wearing a pair of new boots and the bloody walk would never end.
好吧，你为了追求美丽而受苦，而我穿的是合脚的徒步靴。所以我做到了。我的意思是，我看起来很糟糕，但我的脚没有起水泡。经常收听节目的听众会看到照片，他们所不知道的是，我当时在强忍着巨大的痛苦。随着鲜血从信件里渗出、流淌出来……
Well, you suffered to look beautiful, whereas I was wearing sensible walking boots. So I did it. I mean, I look terrible, but I don't have blisters. Regular listeners will have seen the photos and what they won't know is that I was concealing, I was dealing with enormous pain. As the blood dripped, seeped out of the letter um
所以到了中世纪，你知道的，你会有那种非常奇怪、臭名昭著的很长的……是的，教会一直对此大加谴责，但我想其中最臭名昭著的例子就是中国的缠足，还是说并非如此？那只是一种西方神话，还是真的发生过？这背后的故事究竟是什么？哦，这是一个非常有趣的故事。而且，再次强调，我一直在强调这些都是复杂的故事。这不仅仅是说来自，你知道的，亚洲的女性在缠足。欧洲的男女其实也——我们在为在巴达（Bata）举办的名为“时尚受害者”的展览做研究时发现，我的意思是，我们研究了这些鞋底窄得不可思议的
so the middle ages you know you have these kind of very faint notoriously long kind of um yes which the church is always fulminating against but i suppose the most notorious uh example of this is foot binding in china or is it not is that a kind of a western myth or did that really happen what's the kind of story behind that? Oh, it's so it's such an interesting story. And again, I keep stressing that they're complex stories. It's not just sort of like people from, you know, women from Asia were binding their feet. European men and women were also actually we found out when we were doing research for the exhibition that we did called Fashion Victims at the Bada. That I mean, we looked at these incredibly narrow-soled
欧洲鞋子。而且，你知道的，它们非常窄，鞋底还有磨损，所以它们肯定被穿过。但我们当时正试图想象，还有靴子——时尚的，这同样与阶级有关。窄脚被认为是优雅的，无论是对男性还是女性来说，小脚都是如此。所以我们当时在想，你知道，这是怎么做到的？我们查阅了诸如足病医生手册之类的资料，上面谈到人们实际上会，你知道的，欧洲男女会字面意义上地把脚趾绑起来，你知道的，把它们叠放在彼此上面，只为了能塞进这些鞋子里并保持束缚状态。所以我想历史上欧洲存在着大量的足部疼痛。但中国这个经常被用作对比的例子——特别是当传教士进入亚洲地区时，像进入亚洲那样——试图禁止这种做法并试图，你知道的，但他们也对此着迷。
European shoes as well. And, you know, they were so narrow, and they had wear on the soles, so they must have been worn. But we were trying to sort of imagine, and boots, stylish, again, it was class-related. A narrow foot was considered elegant, a tiny foot for both men and women. And so we were trying to think, you know, how did this happen? And we looked into things like chiropodists manuals, and it was talking about how people would actually, you know, European men and women would literally bind their toes, you know, and kind of stack them on each other just to get into these shoes and keep them bound. So I think there was a lot of foot pain historically in Europe. But the example of China, which was used as a comparison often, especially as missionaries going into Asian places where this like into Asia, we're trying to ban it and trying to, you know, but we're also fascinated by it.
这种做法——巴达鞋博物馆的馆长，我想，给出了一个很好的类比。这有点类似于正畸牙齿。这就像是试图去改变上流社会的习俗，但是，你知道的，它只在中国某些地区存在。他们会缠足，在脚周围缠上绷带，以便脚趾会向下折叠。然后你会创造出这种非常小巧且有吸引力的、被称为“三寸金莲”的东西。因此，这——而且女性当然可以走路。我的意思是，这就是那种传说，即人们无法像这样走路。我的意思是，关于这一点肯定有很多很好的文献，我想。女性会绣出这些漂亮的拖鞋来搭配这些脚，以向人展示。这就像欧洲社会中对脚趾的束缚一样。它是为了展示你是多么精英。当然，你的行动越不便，你就越精英，对吧？
That practice was the curator of the Bata Shoe Museum, I think, gives a good analogy. It was sort of something like orthodontics. It was like trying to actually change upper class practice, but, you know, it was only in certain regions of China. They would bind the feet and pull bands around it so that the toes would sort of fold under. And you would create this very small and attractive, what was called a lotus foot. And so this, you know, and certainly women could walk. I mean, that's the kind of the legend that, you know, no people couldn't walk like this. I mean, it's certainly there's lots of good literature on it, I think. And women would embroider these beautiful slippers to wear with these feet to kind of show them off. that was just like the binding of toes in European society. It was meant to show how elite you were. And of course, the less mobile you are, the more elite you are, right?
你不需要走路和从事体力劳动。所以，你知道的，这是炫耀性消费，正如托斯坦·凡勃伦（Thorstein Veblen）会做的那样——或者他创造了“炫耀性消费”这个词，但除此之外还有炫耀性展示。他的许多作品都在谈论，你越能展示你的白衬衫胸前部分，或者任何，你知道的，你干净的袖口和领子，它就越能展示，你知道的，你根本不需要做多少工作，或者你穿着无需走动的服装，你知道的。我认为很多听众都会产生一个显而易见的想法，当我们听到关于缠足的事情时，我们会不由自主地战栗，然后以一种居高临下的态度说“多么疯狂”。但当然，我的意思是，许多听众，也许在他们听这个播客的同时，正穿着非常不切实际的高跟鞋。我不知道有多少穿高跟鞋的听众，有多少人穿上高跟鞋来听我们的播客。无论如何，你是否认为它们在某种程度上与缠足处于同一连续体上，试图塑造足部，试图给人留下深刻印象，但也包含了一些——坦率地说，对于我这个不穿高跟鞋的人来说——看起来非常疯狂的东西。绝不，汤姆。绝不。甚至连试都没试过。看起来很疯狂。
You don't have to walk and perform labor. And so, you know, this is conspicuous display, as Thorstein Veblen would, or he coined the term conspicuous consumption, but there's also conspicuous display. And a lot of his work talks about how the more you can display your white shirt front or any, you know, your clean cuffs and collar, it shows, you know, how little work you have to do or the dress that you don't have to move in, you know. The obvious thing that I think will have occurred to a lot of listeners is we listen to that about the foot binding and we kind of shudder and say how crazy
我的意思是，我妻子每次穿高跟鞋时都会说我在受罪，我的意思是，你认为未来的世代回首这段历史时，会像我们回首前辈那样感到同样的目瞪口呆吗？嗯，我认为尤其是在疫情的背景下，我们抛弃了很多不舒服的东西和束缚性的东西，包括我的——我想自从疫情开始以来，我大概就没穿过高跟鞋。我认为着装变得更加休闲、舒适。我们对舒适度的重视是过去的时代和其他文化中所没有的。就像它只是，我不知道。我的意思是，也许，一方面，有人可能会说：“哦天哪，这在我们现在穿着舒适服装的人看来似乎更加令人震惊。”但我认为最好不要去评判，因为我们都经历过那种穿着时髦服装的感觉。
in our sort of condescending way. But of course, I mean, lots of listeners, maybe while they're listening to this podcast are wearing very impractical high heels. I don't know how many high-heeled listeners, how many people put on their high heels to listen to our podcast. But anyway, do you see them as being on the same sort of continuum in a way as kind of foot binding, trying to shape the foot, trying to create an impression, but also something that, frankly, to me as a non-high heel wearer, looks kind of crazy. Never, Tom. Never. Never even tried it. Looks kind of crazy.
而那正是当时的时尚。那才是时髦的。那也是当时让人感觉良好的东西——关于他们的外表，难道人们为了时尚而忍受痛苦不总是带有一种轻微的声望，让它变得更有价值吗？难道你不认为——你认为存在着一种——我的意思是，因为这里面也发生了一种“快乐与痛苦并存”的机制，不是吗？当然，高跟鞋的拜物教化就是其中的一部分，它们之所以痛苦是快乐的一部分，我想这就和紧身胸衣一样，对吧？紧身胸衣正是如此，我认为——我的意思是，再次强调，特别是对我们而言，我认为这就是我们做出这种区别的方式……不过，也有人觉得穿紧身胸衣更舒服，他们觉得
I mean, my wife always, when she wears high heels says i'm in agony um i mean do you think future generations will look back on that with as much sort of stupefaction as we look back on our predecessors well i think particularly in the context of the pandemic where we've ditched a lot of uncomfortable things um and constraining things including my i don't think I've worn a pair of heels since it started. I think dress has become much more casual, comfortable. We have had an emphasis on comfort that wasn't there in past eras and other cultures. Like it just, it's, I don't know. I mean, I think maybe, I mean, on the one hand, one could say, oh my goodness, this seems even more shocking, you know, now to us as we have this comfortable dress. But I think it's best not to kind of judge because we all know the sensation of, you know, having something fashionable.
有结构感，有支撑感，所以我的博士生写了一篇关于紧身胸衣的论文，她穿着紧身胸衣进行了答辩，而且她——她——她在学术会议上也穿着紧身胸衣做报告。她穿着紧身胸衣进行了论文答辩，而且她，你知道的，她在会议发言时也会穿紧身胸衣，因为这让她感到有支撑感和舒适感。她称它们为一个“拥抱”。所以，你知道的，这在很大程度上是相对的，我认为，取决于你对什么感到舒适。而在过去，我的意思是，并不是每个人都在把紧身胸衣系得死死的，或者，你知道的，不一定非要把自己塞进那些鞋子里。尽管如果你想展现一个时髦的外表，你就必须这样做。所以我不知道。我不知道，我想这是我们关于时尚的神话的一部分。说到高跟鞋，我的意思是，它能增高。所以有一件令人惊叹的花瓶——来自波斯的一个罐子，大约是公元前800年到公元前900年的样子——它有两只脚，
And that's what was fashionable. That was what was stylish. That's what made people feel also good at the time. So about their appearance isn't there always a slight cachet if people suffer for their fashion it becomes more valuable do you not do you think i mean do you think there's a sort of i mean because there's also this kind of like pleasure pain thing going on a little bit isn't there certainly the sort of the fetishization of high heels is part of that the fact that they're painful is part of the pleasure and i suppose detail with corsets yeah with corsets exactly i think i mean that's incorporate i mean again especially for us i think that's how we make that distinction um some people feel more comfortable in corsets too though they feel
而且它有——你知道的，有两条腿从花瓶底部伸出来——所以你可以用这两条腿把它支撑起来，而这些脚穿着高跟鞋。多米尼克，你还记得我们做过一期关于波斯的节目，是的，抱歉，谈到关于波斯发明了高跟鞋的种种说法，嗯，具体来说是平台鞋，平台高跟鞋，显而易见，国王们穿它们是为了让自己显得更高，为了在众多朝臣中鹤立鸡群，而我——你知道的，这似乎是许多不同文化中宫廷生活的一个特征。许多——尼古拉·萨科齐（Nicholas Sarkozy）就穿高跟鞋，是的，他穿了，是的，就像——是的，我的共同研究员伊丽莎白·萨莫哈克（Elizabeth Samohak）说，你知道的，牛仔也穿鞋跟，但我们不称它们为高跟鞋。我们不认为他们穿的是高跟鞋，但他们的确穿了。
structured they feel supported um so my phd student who wrote her thesis on corsets she did her defense in a corset and she's you know she she gives conference presentations in corsets. She did her defense in a corset and she's, you know, she, she gives conference presentations in corsets because they make her feel, um, supported and comfortable. She calls them a hug. So, you know, it's, it's sort of all relative, I think, to, um, now to what you're comfortable with. Whereas in the, in the past, I mean, not everyone was tight lacing their corsets or, you know, um, necessarily squeezing themselves into those shoes. Although if you wanted to present a fashionable facade, you had to. So I don't know. I don't have a, I guess it's part of our myth about fashion, I think, you know. With heels, I mean, it raises you. So there's this amazing vase, kind of pot from um persia about i think about 800 bc 900 bc um and it has two feet
你知道的，他们是男子气概的化身。但她对波斯的鞋履做了大量研究。这很有趣，因为，是的，它们曾是——英国人的一种军用时尚，为了让脚固定在马镫里。所以，你知道的，它最早是在英国被男性采用的。仅仅30年之后，女性，你知道的，是的，它成了权力的象征，女性将其占为己有。而且她们——她们认为，你知道的，她们想变得像这些穿高跟鞋的男人一样。所以它变得非常具有女性的性别色彩，但它取决于，如果你想想萨科齐，如果你想想，你知道的，如果你想想牛仔，没错。那么，嗯，那么，是的——我的意思是，高跟鞋更具……
and the it has kind of you know two legs coming off the the bottom of the vase so you stand it on on the legs and the feet have high heels and dominic you'll remember we did an episode on persia with yes sorry talking about how everything said it invented high heels well specifically platform platform shoes obviously and the kings wear them to make them taller to make them tower over the rest of the courtiers and i you know that seems to be a feature of of kind of courtly life in in many different cultures many nicholas nicholas sarkozy wore high heels yes he did he did yes like yes my co-investigator elizabeth um samohack says you know, cowboys wear heels, but we don't call them. We don't think of them as wearing high heels, but they do.
这个花瓶底部有两只脚，你可以用这些脚支撑它，脚上穿着高跟鞋。多米尼克，你可能还记得我们做过一期关于波斯的节目，是的，抱歉，我们谈到了波斯人如何发明了高跟鞋——准确地说是厚底鞋——国王穿它们是为了让自己更高，在朝臣面前显得高大。你知道，这似乎是许多不同文化中宫廷生活的一个特点。尼古拉·萨科齐就穿过高跟鞋，是的，他穿过，就像我的共同调查员伊丽莎白·萨莫哈克所说的那样，牛仔也穿高跟鞋，虽然我们不称其为高跟鞋，也不认为他们穿的是高跟鞋，但他们确实穿了。
You know, they're the kind of epitome of masculinity. But she did a lot of research on Persian footwear. And it's interesting because, yes, they were something that, you know, the British, it was a military fashion to keep your foot in a stirrup. And so, you know, it was adopted in the UK first by men. And only 30 years later, women, you know, yeah, it was a power symbol, women appropriated it. And they, they thought, you know, they wanted to be like these men in heels. So it's become very gendered feminine, but it depends on, you know, if you think of Sarkozy, if you think of, you know, if you think of, you know, the cowboy or, exactly. Then, um then yeah i mean heels are more um
你知道，他们是男子气概的化身。但她对波斯鞋履做了大量研究。这很有趣，因为，是的，英国人曾经穿过这种鞋，这是一种为了把脚固定在马镫里的军事时尚。所以，你知道，它最早是在英国被男性采用的。仅仅30年後，女性也采用了它，是的，这是一个权力的象征，女性借鉴了它。她们想成为像这些穿高跟鞋的男性那样的人。所以现在它变得非常有女性化的性别特征，但具体情况取决于，你知道，如果你想到萨科齐，如果你想到牛仔，完全是这样。然後，嗯，然後是的，我是说高跟鞋更像
exactly yes elton john yeah elton so i but i suppose something else that makes you look tall if you're a man is a is a top hat uh yes or you know or any kind of hat uh hat wear headwear god i'm getting my wares all over the place um and just but before we come to the break in a way i mean one of the most extraordinary stories of the lot that you tell in in fashion victims is the story of the hat and how these are lethally dangerous and i had i mean until i read your book i had no idea just how dangerous they are although of course i should have done because the mad hatter in yes in lewis carroll of course i again i hadn't thought why hatters are mad just tell us what the hell's
完全是的，埃elton john，对，埃elton，所以，不过我想，如果你是个男士，还有什么东西能让你看起来很高呢？那就是大礼帽，嗯，是的，或者你知道的，或者任何一种帽子，嗯，帽子，头饰，天哪，我的货品到处都是，嗯，在进入中场休息之前，从某种程度来说，你在《时尚受害者》中讲述的最非寻常的故事之一，就是帽子的故事，以及它们是如何具有致命危险的，在读你的书之前，我根本不知道它们有那么危险，尽管我当然应该知道，因为刘易斯·卡罗尔笔下的疯帽子先生，是的，当然，我再次没有想过为什么帽子制造商会疯掉，给我们讲讲到底是怎么回事吧
going on with hats because it's a very weird story i love hats um uh well we should we should tell the listeners that you actually have a hat with you that because we were talking about how dan jackson wore his capitalist hat. A magnificent look. That is a good hat. It's a very good hat. I have a very nice hat made for me by the saucy milliner in Ottawa. Shout out to the saucy milliner.
关于帽子，因为这是一个非常诡异的故事，我喜欢帽子，嗯，嗯，我们应该告诉听众，你其实随身带了一顶帽子，因为我们刚才在讨论丹·杰克逊是怎么戴他的资本家帽子的。真是个绝佳的造型。那确实是一顶好帽子。这是一顶非常好的帽帽。我有一顶非常漂亮的帽子，是渥太华的“时髦女帽商”为我定制的。向“时髦女帽商”致敬。
A shout out to her. And she told me it had magic properties. And I'm assuming it's non-toxic, which is great. Yes, but it doesn't kill you. It would be one magic property. Exactly. I don't know, peacock feathers were used in its making here, apparently. But I hope the peacock wasn't harmed. But I wore it for my book launch, actually.
向她致敬。她告诉我这帽子有魔法属性。我猜它是无毒的，这太棒了。是的，不过它不会要你的命。这倒算是一种魔法属性。确实。我不知道，据说它的制作过程中用到了孔雀羽毛。不过我希望孔雀没有受到伤害。其实我戴着它去参加了我的新书发布会。
So that was a special Top Hat book launch extravaganza. But I have always been fascinated with hats. I have my grandfather's top hat from the 1930s. And it's a silk top hat. So I think it's all right. But in fact, what I realized doing this research, you know, we think of the silk topper, I think it was actually meant to be, nothing talks about this, but I think it was actually meant to be a kind of a non-toxic alternative to the traditional fur felt hat, the beaver or rabbit fur felt hat. And the other little tidbit, I guess I would have that came out of this research was understanding that, you know, animals, basically, they say, you know, any animal that walked by a hatter was in danger
所以那是一场特别的“大礼帽”新书发布会盛典。但我一直对帽子着迷。我有一顶我祖父在20世纪30年代留下的高顶礼帽。那是顶丝质高顶礼帽。所以我觉得它应该没事。但事实上，当我进行这项研究时，我意识到，你知道，我们认为丝质礼帽——我想它其实本来是……虽然没人提过这个，但我认为它其实本来是传统毛皮毡帽的一种无毒替代品，也就是海狸毛或兔子毛毡帽。另一个小八卦，我想我从这次研究中得出的收获是了解到，你知道，基本上动物，他们说，你知道，任何从制帽匠身边走过的动物都有生命危险
of its life. So all sorts of different animals were used to make felt. So this material for these hats that were fashionable from the medieval period to the 1960s, when that's the only time that the whole mercury issue stopped because hats went out of fashion. So, you know, centuries of mercury were used to create, well, not were used to create the hats that adorned the heads, mostly of men, not were used to create the hats that adorned the heads, mostly of men, not exclusively, but mostly. And men didn't leave the house without, just as a woman wouldn't leave the house without her, you know, her crinoline or what she needed in that period. A man would not leave the house without his hat. And so, and certainly a fur felt hat was originally a luxury. It was made of beaver fur. And just to interrupt a second, the mercury, the point of the mercury is what? That it softens the fur, basically. Is that it, effectively?
它的生命。所以各种不同的动物都被用来制作毡帽。因此，从中古时期到20世纪60年代一直很流行的这些帽子的材料，正是在那个时期，由于帽子不再流行，整个汞中毒的问题才停止了。所以，你知道，几个世纪以来，汞一直被用来制造，嗯，其实不是用来制造装饰在人们头上的帽子——主要是男人的头上，不是用来制造装饰在人们头上的帽子——主要是男人的头上，虽然不全是，但主要是。而且男人们出门不能不戴帽子，就像女人出门不能不穿裙撑或者不带那个时期必需的东西一样。男人出门是绝对不能不戴帽子的。所以，而且毛皮毡帽最初绝对是一种奢侈品。它是用海狸毛制作的。打断一下，汞的作用是什么？基本上就是让毛皮变软吗？是这样吗，实际上？
Yes. Well, you know, hat making was a very complex trade. You had to go through many operations to turn this sort of pelt that you would start with into a lovely, lustrous, waterproof, beautiful hat. And if you were doing that with beaver, beaver had a natural felting ability, it was wonderful. But when you start to run out of beaver in the 18th century, for various reasons, I mean, it had been killed off in Europe, you know, by the Renaissance. And then, so people turn to that huge, you know, people know about the fur trade, it was all in service of mostly men's European men's hats. They start to run out of beaver supplies in the 18th century and they need to turn to more locally available and cheaper hats
是的。嗯，你知道，制帽是一门非常复杂的行当。你必须经过许多工序，才能把你最初得到的这种兽皮变成一顶可爱、有光泽、防水、美丽的帽子。如果你用海狸皮来做，海狸皮天生具有制毡性能，这很棒。但到了18世纪，由于种种原因，你开始用光海狸皮，我的意思是，它在文艺复兴时期就已经在欧洲被捕杀殆尽了。然后，人们转向了那个庞大的，你知道的，人们都知道皮草贸易，它基本上都是为了满足欧洲男人的帽子需求。他们在18世纪开始用光海狸皮的供应，于是他们需要转向更容易获得且更便宜的帽子
or cheaper fur, which meant hare and rabbit for the most part. You know, they reproduce, they breed like rabbits, you can eat them. But the problem is rabbit fur or hare fur does not felt very well. And so this is when the whole mercury situation started to happen, because they realized that by brushing the fur with mercury, it changed the chemical composition. And it was mercury and nitric acid, which is also pretty nasty. And you would just brush this onto the pelt and it would turn it orange, actually. It was called kerating, which I think is quite funny in relation to rabbits. But it was kerating. In French, it was called secrétage because the ingredients were secret. So this is one of the reasons it isn't that well known. It was a process that was kind of kept secret and kept within the hiding industry. And so yeah, that would transform the fur and allow you to felt it. But as you can imagine, the fur is just imbued with this horribly toxic quicksilver.
或者更便宜的毛皮，在很大程度上这意味着野兔和家兔。你知道的，它们的繁殖力很强，像兔子一样繁殖，你还可以吃它们。但问题是兔毛或野兔毛的制毡性能并不好。所以这就是整个汞中毒情况开始发生的时候，因为他们发现通过用汞刷洗毛皮，它改变了化学成分。那是汞和硝酸，这也是相当刺激的化学品。你只要把这个刷到兽皮上，它实际上会变成橙色。这被称为“酸处理”（kerating），我觉得这个词和兔子联系在一起挺搞笑的。但它确实是酸处理。在法语里，这被称为“秘密处理”（secrétage），因为配方成分是秘密的。所以这也是它不太为人所知的原因之一。这是一个被当成秘密保守并留在制帽行业内部的工艺。所以，是的，这会改变毛皮的结构并让你能够把它做成毡。但正如你所想象的，毛皮里浸透了这种极其有毒的水银。
And, you know, to make a hat, one of the steps, for example, is called a planking kettle. You immerse it to shrink the felts in this hot water. And just the vapor coming off of that kettle, you would be inhaling it and it would land on roofs. It would go into water supplies. It would poison all of the local soil and water and for a long long time right i mean the mercury is still there in places where there were it is it's you know it still is released into long island sound from danbury in connecticut which was a fur felt uh hat making kind of area in connecticut and yeah they they i mean the hats themselves are still toxic so and and and brit and British hatters, am I right in saying British hatters?
而且，你知道，制作帽子的一道工序，举个例子，叫做“煮毡桶”。你要把它浸入这热水中来收缩毛毡。仅仅是从那个桶里散发出来的蒸汽，你就会把它们吸进去，它会落在屋顶上。它会进入水源。它会污染当地所有的土壤和水，而且持续很长时间，对吧？我的意思是，水银至今仍然存在于曾经有这种厂的地方，它，你知道的，它仍然在从康涅狄格州的丹伯里释放到长岛海湾，康涅狄格州曾经是一个毛皮毡帽制作的集中区，而且，是的，它们，我的意思是帽子本身仍然是有毒的，所以，而且英国的制帽匠，我说英国制帽匠没错吧？
English hatters were using mercury still in the late 1960s. Yes, it was never banned. It was just simply, you know, they tried to invent ways to circumvent it and better solutions, but it was just the cheapest and the most efficient way to create headgear for men. Again, it's a bit like the tutus. People knew that something was wrong. and the most efficient way to create headgear for men. Again, it's a bit like the tutus. People knew that something was wrong because hatters went mad. I mean, is that basically the – is that too simplistic or is that really what happened?
英国制帽匠在20世纪60年代末还在使用汞。是的，它从未被禁止。只是很简单地，你知道，他们试图发明各种方法来绕过它，寻找更好的解决方案，但它仍然是为男士制作头饰最便宜、最有效的方法。再说一次，这有点像芭蕾舞短裙。人们知道有些事情不对劲，但却是为男士制作头饰最有效的方法。再说一次，这有点像芭蕾舞短裙。人们知道有些事情不对劲，因为制帽匠都变疯了。我的意思是，基本上就是——这是一种过于简单的说法，还是说这真的是发生的事情？
I mean, they had a reputation, certainly, for, you know, heavy drinking and kind of eccentric behaviour, I think. Hanging out with hares at tea parties and all that kind of stuff. Exactly tea parties exactly hanging out with the hairs that would have been turned into hats actually thinking about it of course yes i hadn't thought about i know and actually um the other little side note sidebar here was that i realized the magic trick the kind of epitome of magic of pulling the hair out of the or the rabbit out of the hat that was actually a 19th century trick. And in fact, the joke was that, you know, the dead rabbit was, he was reanimating it and bringing it magically back to life, which I, when I realized that I was like, oh my God, how did I not know?
我的意思是，它们确实以酗酒和某种古怪的行为而闻名，我想。在茶会上跟野兔厮混之类的。完全是茶会上，完全是跟那些本会被做成帽子的野兔厮混，仔细想想的话，当然，对啊，我怎么没想到。我懂，而且，嗯，这里的另一个小插曲是，我意识到那个魔术把戏——从帽子里拽出兔子的那种魔术的精髓——其实是19世纪的把戏。事实上，当时的笑话是，你知道，那只死兔子，他在让它复活，用魔术让它起死回生，当我意识到这一点时，我心想，天哪，我怎么会不知道？
But, but of course that's magic. I think that's a perfect note on which to have a break. And when we come back, we'll look at another cheery aspect of fashion, which is its fondness for um poisons other than mercury uh chiefly uses dyes cosmetics and so on so um lots of fun to come i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our qA we pull back the curtain
但，但当然这就是魔术。我认为这是一个完美的切入点，让我们休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将探讨时尚的另一个令人愉快的方面，那就是它对除汞之外的其他毒药的喜爱——主要用于染料、化妆品等等，所以，嗯，接下来会有很多有趣的内容。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《一切皆娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱
on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. In the 1827 dialogue between fashion and death by the Italian romantic poet Giacomo Lepardi, he has a personification of fashion who claims that she is death's sister. She says she's proudly playing many deadly games, crippling people with tight shoes, cutting off their breath and making their eyes pop out because of their tight corsets now i've talked about corsets we've talked about shoes what we haven't talked about though um are colors and i guess the color green is a good place to start basically i mean this is a very very simplistic way of putting it but in the 19th century green
并告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的本质》（The Rest Is History）。在意大利浪漫主义诗人贾科莫·莱帕尔迪1827年创作的对话《时尚与死亡》中，他将“时尚”拟人化，时尚声称自己是死亡的妹妹。她说她自豪地玩着许多致命的游戏，用紧绷的鞋子弄残人们，让他们因为紧身胸衣而喘不过气来、眼珠突出来。既然我已经谈过了紧身胸衣，谈过了鞋子，但我们还没有谈过的，嗯，是颜色。我想绿色是个很好的起点。基本上，这是一个非常非常简单的说法：在19世纪，绿色
will probably kill you i mean green, green hats, green fabrics, if you work in a factory using green dye. And Alison, why- Who is wearing green. Yes, who is wearing green. I am wearing my emerald green dress. Boldly. Again.
可能会要你的命。我是说绿色，绿色的帽子，绿色的织物，如果你在工厂里使用绿色染料工作。而艾莉森，为什么——谁在穿绿色。是的，谁在穿绿色。我穿着我的祖母绿绿色连衣裙。非常大胆地。又来了。
What's going on there? Why will that kill you? Oh, and just as a preface, I would have been the person dying of emerald green because as you can tell from the dress I'm wearing today, I'm not the radio listeners, but green is my favorite color. But yes, in the 19th century, I mean, if we think about it in a broader perspective, it was a period that saw so much urbanization and industrialization. And you can imagine kind of people coming in from a green countryside and entering an urban environment where it was green
那到底是怎么回事？为什么那会要你的命？哦，作为前言，我本来就会是那个死于祖母绿绿的人，因为正如你从我今天穿的这条裙子能看出来的——虽然广播听众看不见——但绿色是我最喜欢的颜色。但是，是的，在19世纪，如果我们从更广阔的角度来看，这是一个见证了如此大规模城市化和工业化的时期。你可以想象，人们从绿色的乡村来到一个绿色的
might have been a lot harder to come by. And so green was sought after, I suppose. But it was also technically one of the hardest colours to achieve. Because historically, and now I've taken up natural dyeing during the pandemic. So as a hobby, I now know that green is very difficult to create, because you really do have to have two dye baths, you have to have a yellow, which is easy to find, but you also need a blue, which would come from like mowed or imported indigo. And the shade that was created by Sheila, who was a Pomeranian chemist in 1770s, was only achievable through chemistry. It was not like kind of a new form of chemistry. And, you know, green had all sorts of other problems, like you would have a green outfit, but and it might look nice in daylight, but it would look gray, either on the stage or at night.
可能很难觅得的城市环境中。所以绿色备受追捧，我想。但从技术上讲，它也是最难实现的颜色之一。因为在历史上——现在我在大流行期间开始学习天然染色了。所以作为一个爱好，我现在知道绿色非常难调制，因为你真的必须要有两个染缸，你必须有一种黄色的染料，这很容易找到，但你还需要一种蓝色，这要从像菘蓝或进口的靛蓝中提取。这种由1770年代的波美拉尼亚化学家希勒创造的色调，只能通过化学手段来实现。这不像是某种新形式的化学。而且，你知道，绿色还有各种各样其他的问题，比如你可能会有一套绿色的衣服，它在白天可能看起来很好看，但在舞台上或晚上就会变成灰色。
So you didn't want a green gown, because it would kind of not be very colorful in most lighting situations that you'd want to be splendid in. This new green that Sheila created had many different names, but it was created using arsenic trioxide and copper, which had long been used in the making of greens. But the arsenic was, I think, somewhat new. And he managed, and it was kind of improved and they added different, made different formula. And then by the 1820s or so, it was being used for so many consumer goods. It was being used for paper, wallpaper, paint, you know, as a pigment, toys, candies, you know, just by the Victorian period, it was everywhere.
所以你不会想要一件绿色的礼服，因为它在大多数你想让自己光芒四射的照明情况下都不会显得很有色彩。希勒创造的这种新绿色有很多不同的名字，但它是用三氧化二砷和铜制成的，这两种物质长期以来一直被用于制造绿色。但砷这种成分，我想在某种程度上是新的。他成功了，而且它在某种程度上得到了改进，他们添加了不同的成分，制造出了不同的配方。到了18世纪20年代左右，它被用于如此多的消费品中。它被用在纸张、壁纸、油漆中，你知道的，作为一种颜料，玩具、糖果，你知道的，到了维多利亚时期，它无处不在。
And it always has arsenic in it, just to be clear. But the arsenic is a key ingredient, isn't it, that people are using a lot? Yes. So have I got this right, that a ball gown would have enough arsenic to kill 200 people? Well, I mean, if you think about it, this is exactly the same period of the crinoline. So, you know, a ball gown would be many, many layers of different fabrics, including one called tarlatan, which, you know, was also used for tutus, not green. But it was kind of a rough weave and they would just have the pigment would kind of dust off of it. You know, you'd have yards and yards of this bright green fabric and the pigment wasn't that solidly attached sometimes. So a dress like that, maybe, potentially, they certainly, people who are
而且它里面一直都含有砷，把话说清楚。但砷是一个关键成分，对吧？人们大量使用它？是的。所以我理解得对吗，一件舞会礼服里的砷含量足以杀死200人？嗯，我的意思是，如果你仔细想想，这正是撑裙盛行的同一时期。所以，你知道，一件舞会礼服会有很多很多层不同的面料，其中包括一种叫做塔夫绸（tarlatan）的面料，你知道的，它也被用于芭蕾舞短裙，虽然不是绿色的。但它是一种粗织面料，颜料会从上面脱落。你知道的，你会有好几码这种亮绿色的面料，而且颜料有时附着得并不是那么牢固。所以像这样的裙子，也许，有可能，他们当然，那些
trying to kind of argue that this was harming the flower makers and dressmakers and the people who dyed the fabric were getting the foremost, you know, analytical chemists in the world and forensic chemist Hoffman, who is also a dye chemist, to test these things and to use these kind of techniques that had been developed for arsenic poisoning trials, the Reinsch test and the Marsch test, to test textiles and fabrics. And those were the results that they came up with. So I don't know if it was exaggerated, but it's quite possible. There was a lot of arsenic.
试图争辩说这正在伤害花朵制造商、女裁缝以及给面料染色的人的学者们，找来了世界上最顶尖的分析化学家和法医化学家霍夫曼（也是一位染料化学家）来对这些东西进行测试，并使用为砷中毒审判开发的那些技术，比如雷因施试验（Reinsch test）和马什试验（Marsh test）来测试纺织品和面料。这些就是他们得出的结果。所以我不知道这是否被夸大了，但这是完全可能的。这里面有大量的砷。
Because, Alison, I mean, again, and this is a theme running throughout this discussion, people knew that these dresses were potentially dangerous. So you have a joke in punch and the jokes in punch are never really, I mean, they never seem particularly funny to us, but this seems positively, I mean, the opposite of funny. We think a man would be as green as the dress of his fair partner if he either waltzed or polked with a lady in shields green in fact girls in these green dresses ought to be marked dangerous or to have beware of poison embroidered in red letters right across the back i mean it's a making it as a joke but that seems to be saying yeah we know these dresses are absolutely lethal advice columns for women saying you know bring some ammonia in
因为，艾莉森，我的意思是，同样地，这也是贯穿整个讨论的一个主题，人们知道这些裙子可能具有危险性。所以你在《Punch》杂志上看到过一个笑话，而《Punch》里的笑话从来都不是真正的——我的意思是，它们在我们看来似乎从来都不是特别有趣，但这看起来绝对是——我的意思是，跟有趣截然相反。我们认为，如果一个男人与一位穿谢尔斯绿（Scheele's green）裙子的女士跳华尔兹或波尔卡舞，他就会变得和舞伴的裙子一样绿。事实上，穿着这些绿色裙子的女孩应该被标上“危险”字样，或者在后背正中绣上醒目的红字“小心毒物”。我的意思是，这把它当成了一个笑话，但那似乎是在说：是的，我们知道这些裙子绝对是致命的。给女性的建议专栏写道：如果你想看看绿色中是否含有砷，可以在气味盐瓶里带一些氨水
your smelling salts bottle if you want to see if the green has arsenic so if you pour the ammonia on it um it will turn blue because of the copper and that's probably arsenical so don't buy that one so you know there was consumer advice on but people surely aren't going into like you know late victorian department stores or something armed pouring chemicals no although we did try it in the lab with some lemon scented ammonia and it worked it did turn blue we were playing with the arsenic in the long run this this does kind of start to percolate through and and you say is that am i right that this is why coco chanel hated green she never used green yes i think these i've heard since many stories of you know people entering sort of the danish theater wardrobe department you know, being warned off using green thread. And this is in the 20th century. So or 21st century, even. So there are lots of suspicions still that and Chanel being one of them, the House of Chanel, Chanel thought it was an unlucky color, but she was trained as a milliner and as a seamstress in her teachers would have probably encountered um encountered arsenical greens in the course of their work because it was especially bad for
如果你把氨水倒在上面，嗯，它会因为铜的作用变成蓝色，那可能就是含砷的，所以别买那件。所以当时确实有消费者指南，但人们肯定不会拿着化学药剂闯进晚期维多利亚时代的百货公司吧？没有，虽然我们确实在实验室里用一些柠檬味的氨水做过实验，而且成功了，它真的变蓝了。我们一直在跟砷打交道。从长远来看，这确实开始渗透进来，而且你说——我没说错吧——这就是为什么香奈儿（Coco Chanel）讨厌绿色，她从不用绿色？是的，我想我后来听到了很多这样的故事，比如人们走进丹麦剧院的服装部，你知道的，被警告不要使用绿色线。这是在20世纪。甚至21世纪。所以仍然有很多这样的怀疑，香奈儿就是其中之一，香奈儿之家的香奈儿认为这是一种不吉利的颜色，但她曾接受过女帽匠和女裁缝的培训，她的老师们在工作中很可能会遇到
artificial flowers and leaves in particular um that that were powdered with this green pigment to make them you know seemingly lifelike but very harmful and i also wrote an article called tainted love on oscar wilde's green carnation which, yeah, I love titles. But on the Green Carnation was a symbol of homosexuality because a kind of coded symbol, because it was an artificial green, right? You could, and you know, a lot of people refer to them as dipped in arsenic. And yeah, it's complicated, but people hadn't made that connection. So just a last point about arsenic, Alison, and a theme that I think runs through your book and through this story, the people who are most at risk are often the people who are making these things, aren't they?
含砷的绿色，因为这对于人造花朵和叶子来说尤其糟糕，这些东西被撒上了这种绿色颜料，使它们看起来栩栩如生，但实际上非常有害。我还写过一篇名为《染血的爱》（Tainted Love）的文章，讲的是王尔德（Oscar Wilde）的绿康乃馨，是的，我很喜欢起标题。但绿康乃馨是同性恋的一个象征，作为一种隐秘的符号，因为它是一种人造绿，对吧？你可以——你知道的，很多人提到它们时都会说那是浸过砷的。是的，情况很复杂，但人们之前并没有把这联系起来。所以关于砷的最后一点，艾莉森，我觉得有一个主题贯穿着你的这本书以及这个故事：承受最大风险的人往往是那些制作这些东西的人，对吧？
A bit like with the hatters. So these people who are working with arsenic, I mean, they have the kind of dust on their hands or whatever, or they have. So do you think there is a sort of silent death toll of people who were dressmakers and textile workers and so on? Definitely. I mean, the conditions of that kind of work were horrific to start with. But if you were working in particularly dangerous corners of it, including, you know, hatting or artificial flower makers in particular, were very much exposed to these. I think a lot of them would have, you know, had, well, a lot of them did have die early deaths, had chronic illnesses. And in fact, I think what's interesting as a
有点像制帽匠。所以这些跟砷打交道的人，我的意思是，他们的手上沾满了这种灰尘之类的，或者他们吸入了。所以你认为那些女裁缝、纺织工人等等，是不是存在一种无声的死亡人数？绝对是的。我的意思是，那种工作的条件本身就已经极其可怕了。但如果你在特别危险的环节工作，包括，你知道的，制帽或者人造花制造商，他们确实非常严重地暴露在这些东西之中。我想他们当中有很多人，你知道的，都——嗯，很多人确实英年早逝，患有慢性病。事实上，我认为有趣的是作为一个
contrast is that, you know, because the consumers weren't harmed in the case of hats, you know, men were not aware that their hats had mercury and they had linings. And so they were kind of protected from this. And if you were a working class man, you were sort of expected to take on the risks of many dangerous jobs, whereas the young girls and women were often working as artificial flower makers, it was very ill paid. And so there was an idea, not only was, you know, were the wearers getting harmed, like people would wear green gloves to the ball gown, and then they'd get a rash or they'd, their wreath would powder, you know, onto their shoulders, their hair wreath out of artificial flowers, and they'd get, again, a rash. So they called the doctor.
对比的是，你知道的，因为消费者在帽子这件事情上没有受到伤害，你知道，男人们并不知道他们的帽子里有汞，而且帽子有衬里。所以他们在某种程度上受到了保护。如果你是个工人阶级的男人，你某种程度上被期望去承担许多危险工作的风险，而那些年轻女孩和妇女则经常做人造花制作工，报酬非常低。所以当时有一种观念，不仅是佩戴者受到伤害——比如人们会戴着绿色手套去参加舞会，然后就会起疹子，或者他们的头饰会掉落粉末，你知道的，用人造花做成的发环会掉到他们的肩膀上，他们的头发上，然后他们又会起疹子。于是他们就会去看医生。
And the same doctors were seeing the flower girls coming into their hospitals for the poor, you know, the next day. And so they were making that connection between the fashionable green and the workers who made it as well and kind of trying to call it out because women, you know, obviously needed more protection. And it was also much more visible, right? Everybody could kind of look for these greens. So Alison, we actually, we have a question on this theme from Lauren MGM on the Discord, who asks about unions and to what extent were our garment worker unions effective in proving worker and consumer safety? So do unions, does the rise of unions play a part as well? It's not just kind of doctors pointing out that these are dangerous. Is it actual, you know, it's workers organizing together and saying, you know, even as early as the 18, one of the things I found fascinating was, you know, in the 1850s, when Baudelaire's writing Les Fleurs du Mal, or The Flowers of Evil, which seems all that more apt, the workers are actually going to protest
而同一批医生第二天就会看到做花女工们来到他们的平民医院。所以他们把时尚的绿色与制作它的工人联系在了一起，并试图大声疾呼，因为女性，你知道的，显然需要更多的保护。而且这也明显得多，对吧？每个人都能注意到这些绿色。所以艾莉森，实际上，我们在Discord上收到了来自Lauren MGM关于这个主题的一个问题，她询问了工会的情况，我们的服装工人工会在证明工人和消费者安全方面发挥了多大程度的作用？所以工会，工会的崛起也起到了作用吗？不仅仅是医生指出这些是有危险的吧？这实际上是，你知道的，工人们组织起来说，你知道的，甚至早在1850年代，我发现最着迷的事情之一就是，你知道的，在1850年代，当波德莱尔写《恶之花》（Les Fleurs du Mal）时，这显得更加贴切，工人们实际上去
at the police prefecture about the danger of their conditions. And, you know, kind of it gets, it does get, arsenic gets banned in France and in Scandinavia and in Germany because it's considered so hazardous. But in the UK, I mean, certainly unions are on the rise and do change conditions, you know, as of the late 19th century and early 20th century in garment industries, I would say. I mean, not that there weren't strikes before and unions, but in terms of the UK, arsenic was such an important good. And they actually, after Matilda Scheurer, who was a 19-year-old flower maker who died of arsenic poisoning from working with Emerald Green, after she died, there was a huge, you know, investigation. And they said, well, you know, really only one person has died. This is, you know, too important to industry, we can't actually ban it. And so it did go out of fashion, because it was, you know, there were kind of ladies, the Ladies Sanitary Association was, you know, again, getting these chemists to prove scientifically about that these things were, you know, toxic and advocating against it. But there weren't, it wasn't, the workers themselves,
警察局抗议他们工作环境的危险。而且，你知道的，这确实引起了重视，砷在法国、斯堪地那维亚和德国被禁了，因为它被认为太危险了。但在英国，我的意思是，当然工会在崛起，并且确实改变了工人的状况，你知道的，从19世纪末和20世纪初的服装行业开始，我会这么说。我的意思是，并不是说之前没有罢工和工会，但在英国，砷是一种如此重要的商品。而且他们实际上，在玛蒂尔达·舍雷尔（Matilda Scheurer）死后——她是一个19岁的人造花工，因为接触祖母绿绿工作而死于砷中毒——在她死后，发生了一场巨大的，你知道的，调查。他们说，好吧，你知道的，其实只有一个人死了。这是，你知道的，对工业太重要了，我们实际上不能禁止它。所以它之所以过时，是因为，你知道的，当时有一些女士，女士卫生协会（Ladies Sanitary Association）——你知道的，再次请这些化学家进行科学证明，证明这些东西是有毒的，并呼吁反对它。但并没有，不是的，工人们自己，
as far as I know, in the artificial flower industry, didn't themselves in the UK protest or unionize. So, although, you know, I did find that eventually after her death, the particular flower shop she worked in, which was near the British Library where I was researching, did move to more spacious and airy premises. So there was slow change. But again, a lot of these girls were minors as well. They didn't have any political power. And it's an ongoing thing, isn't it? Because you have the extraordinary story about the um the the belt sold by asos uh inspired
据我所知，在人造花行业中，英国的工人们并没有自己进行抗议或成立工会。所以，虽然，你知道的，我确实发现在她死后，她工作的那家特定花店——它离我在进行研究的大英图书馆很近——确实搬到了更宽敞、更通风的场所。所以确实有缓慢的改变。但话说回来，很多这些女孩也都是未成年人。她们没有任何政治权力。而且这是一个持续存在的问题，对吧？因为你有一个非同寻常的故事，关于嗯——ASOS出售的一条腰带，灵感来自
by alexander mcqueen uh which was studded and the studs had cobalt 60 in uh and um they were radioactive and um therefore give you a radioactivity you know radioactive poisoning like a superhero's belt if worn more than 500 hours so so it's a kind of ongoing thing and another on i mean really i think this the the kind of the last, and in a way, perhaps again, perhaps up there with foot binding is one of the most famous way through into the present day as well. So the cosmetics that Elizabeth I wears, is it true that it kind of basically, I mean, kind of poisoned her face? As far as we know, it is. And as far as I've been able to see, I mean, and she was certainly not the only one. I mean, having a white complexion, I mean, there are so many racial dimensions to that, I whitening your skin and class as well right i mean it's a class oh definitely you would sun tans didn't become fashionable until the 20s and 30s so 1920s and 30s so definitely until then you wanted um to have if you were uh european or north
亚历山大·麦昆（Alexander McQueen），上面镶有铆钉，而这些铆钉里含有钴-60，嗯，它们具有放射性，嗯，因此如果你佩戴超过500小时，就会产生放射性，你知道的，就像超级英雄的腰带一样会引发放射性中毒。所以这是一种持续存在的东西，还有另一个——我的意思是，真的，我认为这可以说是——这种最后的方式，从某种程度上来说，也许再次与缠足一样，是通往现代的最著名的方式之一。那么伊丽莎白一世所用的化妆品，这是真的吗？它基本上，我的意思是，差不多毁了她的脸？据我们所知，是的。据我所能看到的，我的意思是，而且她当然不是唯一的一个。拥有白皙的肤色，我的意思是，这背后有那么多关于种族的维度，美白你的皮肤，还有阶级，对吧？我的意思是，阶级——哦，绝对是的。直到20世纪20年代和30年代，日晒皮肤才开始流行，所以19年代20和30年代——所以绝对直到那时，如果你是一个欧洲人或北美
american uh you know you wanted to to have the lightest skin possible. That was a sign that, again, just like the constricting and constraining fashions, you weren't out in the fields harvesting things and being exposed to the sun. And you have it in India as well. There's kind of lightning powders that, again, are kind of very dangerous. And they're still sold. Exactly. Some of them also contain mercury i mean yes there's a there's still toxic products used in a lot of these um uh cosmetic products actually and there's still an emphasis on on whitening and lightening which is very harmful
人，你知道的，你想要拥有尽可能白皙的皮肤。那是一个标志，就像那些限制身体和束缚身体的时尚一样，表明你没有在田野里收割农作物并暴露在阳光下。印度也是如此。那里也有那种美白粉，同样，也是非常危险的。而且它们现在还在卖。确实。其中一些也含有铅。我的意思是，是的，许多这些嗯——化妆品中仍然含有有毒产品，事实上，而且仍然强调美白和亮肤，这非常有害。
um so many of these case studies have still have you know continue to have resonance i think today but um but yes i mean having if you think about lead, the properties of lead, I mean, that's why lead was in paint, right? So lead white, because it creates a kind of opaque surface that reflects light as well, right? And so as an ingredient, it gives you this desired, it masks things and makes them look light optically. And that's why it was such a commoning. I mean, it was easy, easily available. So it was, and it wasn't too expensive. So, you know, that was one of the reasons why lead figured in cosmetics, I was still finding in the 19th century, pearl white skin creams that caused
许多这些案例研究在今天仍然具有共鸣，我认为，但是，嗯，是的，拥有——如果你想想铅的特性，我的意思是，这就是为什么油漆里有铅，对吧？比如铅白，因为它能创造出一种不透明的表面，也能反射光线，对吧？所以作为一种成分，它赋予了你这种想要的效用，它能掩盖瑕疵，并在视觉上让它们看起来很亮。这就是为什么它会成为一种如此常见的成分。我的意思是，它很简单，很容易获得。所以它并不太贵。所以，你知道，这就是铅出现在化妆品中的原因之一，我甚至在19世纪还在寻找那些导致
hand drop, and like it was called lead palsy, I believe, in terms of, you know, women putting it on their skins and not being able to move their hands um so there were still products you know i mean historically later on that that uh that contained this um these contained lead and continue to today yes because you have this um amazing figure that a 20 a 2011 study by the fda so it's in america found lead in all 400 of the lipsticks they tested i know i have to admit after that i brought some of my lipsticks to be tested in our physics lab just to see and worked with a friend. And what happened? Well, interestingly, yes, they were because I kind of buy natural brands. But I had my then young son come in with his, he'd gone to circus camp and he had clown makeup and that did have lead in it oh really that's interesting
手下垂的“珍珠白”皮肤霜，你知道的，这被称为铅麻痹（lead palsy），就女性把它涂在皮肤上却无法移动双手而言——所以历史上在晚期仍然有产品，你知道的，包含这种成分，这些产品包含铅，并且今天仍在继续使用。是的，因为你有一个非常惊人的数字，根据美国食品药品监督管理局（FDA）2011年的一项研究——所以这是在美国进行的——在他们测试的所有400支口红中都发现了铅。我知道，我必须承认，在那之后，我把我的一些口红带到了我们的物理实验室进行测试，只是为了看看，我和一个朋友一起合作的。结果怎么样？嗯，有趣的是，是的，它们确实含有，因为我买的算是天然品牌。但我让我当时年幼的儿子带了他的——他去参加马戏夏令营，他有小丑妆，而那个里面确实含有铅。哦，真的吗？那很有趣。
so not so not so funny yeah um but uh but and in fact i as i investigated more and worked with my partner eric de silva in physics um we realized that lead is part of the pigments that color it like it's a natural if you like it's natural ingredient. So it's not required to be listed. It's kind of considered a contaminant, not something you have to list on the label. So it's really quite impossible to know. But what's interesting too, is the FDA also considers it something topical. In other words, something you only put on the outside of your skin. But of course, as we all know, or anyone who's ever worn makeup knows we are eating things and we are you know the the lipstick gets ingested um and you know our skin is only a fine barrier so um anything that's
所以并不是——不是那么好笑，对吧，嗯，但是，嗯——而且事实上，随着我深入调查并与我在物理系的搭档埃里克·德席尔瓦（Eric De Silva）合作，我们意识到铅是给它着色的颜料的一部分，就像它是一种天然成分，如果你愿意这么说的话。所以它不需要被列在成分表上。它被认为是一种污染物，而不是你必须在标签上列出的东西。所以这实际上完全无法得知。但有趣的是，FDA也认为它是一种外用产品。换句话说，是你只涂在皮肤外表的东西。但当然，正如我们所知，或者任何化过妆的人都知道的，我们是在把东西吃下去，我们正在——你知道的——口红会被吞进肚子里，而且，你知道的，我们的皮肤只是一层薄薄的屏障，所以任何被认为
considered adornment is not protected as well as anything that's considered you know medical or anything like that so there's still kind of a bias against that and there still is lead in some cosmetics i mean it's not very well regulated well i i hope that this um so that's actually a chilling thought isn't it that uh we could do this podcast in a hundred people doing this podcast in 100 years and they'd be talking about us well what they'd be talking about botox and well they would i mean these people whose kind of bottoms explode and stuff because they've i mean that's an example of killer fashion isn't it i mean people i mean that's like the foot binding
是装饰品的东西，其受保护的程度都不如被认为具有医疗用途的东西或类似的东西。所以针对这一块仍然有一种偏见，并且某些化妆品中仍然含有铅。我的意思是，它的监管并不是很好。嗯，我希望这——这其实是一个令人不寒而栗的想法，对吧？我们可以在100年后录制这个播客，而100年后的人们可能会在谈论我们。他们会谈论肉毒杆菌之类的东西，嗯，他们会这样做的。我的意思是，这些人因为他们的屁股爆炸之类的东西，因为他们——我的意思是，这就是杀手时尚的一个例子，对吧？我的意思是，人们——这就像缠足的事情，但这次用的是化学制品。没错。当我们审视我们的当代社会以及我们所做的事情，或者新的——我的意思是，每当我们在谈论现在时尚的舒适度时，我总是觉得，它对穿戴者来说可能要舒服得多，但它仍然，你知道的，我们的蓝色牛仔裤经常被进行喷砂处理，导致那些用海滩沙子进行喷砂的工人的肺部患上矽肺病。或者，你知道的，我们可能有舒服的鞋子，比如我们可能喜欢我们的运动鞋，
thing, but also with chemicals. Right. Again, take a second thought when we look at our contemporary society and the things that we do, or the new, I mean, I always think when we were talking about kind of comfort of fashion now, it may be much more comfortable for the wearer, but it's still, you know, our blue jeans are often being sandblasted and causing silicosis in the lungs of the workers blasting it with beach sand. Or, you know, we may have comfortable shoes, like we may love our trainers,
但它们往往是用对做这些工作的工人具有神经毒性的粘合剂粘合在一起的。是的，还有，是谁在制造你的运动鞋？没错。它们真的舒适吗？所以内森·霍格（Nathan Hogg），节目的老朋友，提出了一个问题：真正的时尚受害者是那些血汗工厂的工人吗？绝对是的。作为一名教授时尚学生的老师，我觉得这真的非常重要。作为一名历史学家，我觉得非常重要的一点是指出，你知道的，这些劳工、环境和健康问题，我们，你知道的，这些问题依然存在，而且对于我们这些全球北方的人来说往往是看不见的。
but they're often put together using adhesives that are neurotoxic for the workers doing that. Yeah, and also who's making your trainers? Exactly. Are they comfortable? So there's a question from Nathan Hogg, friend of the show. Are the true fashion victims the many sweatshop workers? Definitely. As someone who teaches fashion students, I felt that it was really important. And as a historian, I felt it was really important to say, you know, these labor and, you know, environmental and health problems that we, you know, that are still going on and often unseen to those of us in the global north.
它们依然在发生。只是我们看得更少。在19世纪，当伦敦、曼彻斯特和巴黎是时尚生产的巨大中心时，医疗界正在亲眼目睹正在发生的事情，他们经常试图提高人们对这些问题的认识。然而现在，然而现在，你知道的，我们意识到了它们的存在，但它们依然在发生。而且它们是在全球范围内发生的。所以，是的，血汗工厂——我的意思是，这是一段悠久的历史，而且它仍在继续。你的书《时尚受害者》对此作了极其精彩的阐述，你刚才说你喜欢起标题。我的意思是，只要看看章节标题，你就有“有毒技术”、“水银帽子”、“有毒颜料”、“含砷绿色”、“纠缠与窒息”、“被机器吞噬”、“易燃面料”、“烈焰芭蕾裙”和“易燃撑裙”，而且正如我所说，插图也同样精美绝伦。这是一本极其迷人的书。非常感谢你来做客。汤姆，你得——你的女儿应该多替我们选一些话题。这是这个播客带来的伟大启示，她也许我可以带着我的犯罪书再来。我们非常欢迎你带着犯罪书再来！等等，等等，所以你还不知道它什么时候出版？也许可以给我们透露个小预告？我会在接下来的两三年内告诉你。那太棒了。不过我的书名依然是《刺伤、捅伤和击打》，就是这样，还有《染血》
They're still happening. They're just we see them less in the in the 19th century. These problems were much, you know, as when London and Manchester and Paris were big centers for the production of fashion, the medical establishment was seeing what was happening and they were often trying to kind of raise awareness of these problems. Whereas now, whereas now, you know, we're aware of them, but they're still happening. And they're happening on a global scale. So yes, the sweatshop, I mean, it's a long history, and it's still going on. Brilliantly explicated in your book, Fashion Victims, and you said you love titles. I mean, just looking at the chapter titles, you've got toxic techniques, mercurial hats, poisonous
好吧，希望到时这个播客还在运营，好让你来谈论那个。艾莉森，非常感谢。你的书叫《时尚受害者》。谢谢。大家快去买吧。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的本质》。想要获取加更节目、提前收听权限、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。
pigments, arsenical greens, entangled and strangled, caught in the machine, inflammatory fabrics, flaming tutus and combustible crinolines and that kind of, and as I say, just magnificently illustrated as well. It's an incredibly fascinating book. Thank you so much for coming on. Tom, you should, your daughter should choose more of our topics. That's the great lesson of this podcast she maybe i'll get to come back with my crime book we would love you to come back with your crime book wait wait so you don't know yet when it's going to be out maybe give us a sneak preview i'll let you know the next two or three years that'd be great but my titles are still shot and stabbed and struck so there we are and stained
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《一切皆娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料的固定节目，
okay well hopefully the podcast will still be running in time for you to come and do that. Alison, thanks so much. Your book, Fashion Fiction Tips. Thank you. Rush out and buy it, guys. Bye-bye. Bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com.
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，并告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip
以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任何句子即可发表评论。
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目
and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及提前购买现场演出门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。